sixteen minutes correspondent John
Dickerson is with us John good morning
morning Anthony we heard from eight
hours of testimony for legal scholars
yesterday on the one hand we had we had
one saying if this isn't impeachable
nothing is another one saying there's
nothing impeachable here where are we
well we're kind of where we are and
where everything is in Washington now
where basically where you sit depends on
where you previously stood and the
process has to go you know a lot longer
further what yesterday was was an
attempt actually to step back from
Washington's normal partisan
polarization and say when they built the
standards for the office in the summer
of 1787 what were they trying to do and
is this president living up to that
standard or has he fallen short but you
can't step back in Washington when you
go back to the Constitution though John
this question really isn't that
complicated is it no it's all of this
testimony yesterday it's at the absolute
center of the presidency what's the
question at stake here the president
used his powers of office for himself
and not his country when they created
the Constitution they've sat George
Washington the front of the room as a
model for building the presidency why
because twice in his career he'd given
up power and not done the thing for
himself but protected the Republic and
they said that's what we want in a
president he both did it when he gave up
his commission as commander of the
Continental Army
and also when his soldiers tried to
stage a coup against the government
Washington heard about the coup and said
how dare you don't you do that you must
protect the Republic that was the model
for the office and that's what's at
question here did the president do
something for himself with those powers
that he's been given so it's at the
center of the presidency impeachment is
always gonna be political it's an
inherently political process but this
one feels particularly partisan what's
the message to Americans tuning in who
think it's just a partisan mud fight
yeah hey you're right
and and and but be let it breathe you
know let the process go forward it's
gonna be messy because it was messy when
Democrats were the ones when I was a
Democratic president who was in the who
was in the hot seat and it's now gonna
be messy when it's a Republican one but
and yet this is why yesterday was
important what's the standard for the
office did this president fall short and
then if he fell short
what's the sanction well the president
his legal team so far refused to
participate in the inquiry
can they can they cry foul if they are
refusing to participate well I mean in
politics they can write but do they have
do they have a legit gripe if you're not
going to participate how can you say
yeah right well that treated unfairly
that's right I mean the the what one of
the weaknesses in the president's case
is the president is saying not only did
I do nothing wrong it was perfect when
his defenders in Congress don't start
with that as their argument but complain
about the process it implicitly
undermines the president's argument if
you were in a trial and you weren't even
in town when the crime you're being
accused of happened you'd want your
defense attorney to say he wasn't even
in town but when they complain about the
process and don't use the president's
argument which is what I did was perfect
it it undermines the president's case so
I what happens now I mean I think people
are looking at it their heads are about
to pop off yeah cuz nothing seems to
change well and you wouldn't expect it
to I mean this is it takes time and so
what happens is you have you know you'll
go now to this question of articles of
impeachment and then presumably based on
what we think because Democrats are in
control the house it'll move over into
the Senate and then you'll have an
actual trial and some of these questions
about whether the President did what's
alleged will actually be adjudicated
under normal rules and Republicans will
be running the show this time yeah
quarters has reported January's already
clear on the Senate calendar they're
expecting to have a trial yeah that's
right and Republicans will be will be
running things and by the way we've also
got a public that's dealing with the
end-of-the-year holidays and all of that
going on and so that's something for
Democrats an electricity bill right and
then we've also got an election campaign
all right John thank you very much